thank you for joining us i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez more than
two years after project neon wrapped up
on on the 15 freeway ndot is planning
another major construction project this
one is going to be on u.s 95. and those
plans call for improvements between
rancho and mojave madison kimbrough live
tonight joining us with why some say
this is really needed madison
yeah you can take a look behind me as we
are right in front of it this is the
downtown access project and it's
focusing on a busy stretch of freeway
and tonight the community had a chance
to see exactly what's in store for this
area
the nevada department of transportation
held a meeting tuesday night to go over
their three-part project in creating
better access to the downtown area of
las vegas ryan wheeler senior project
manager for ndot says upgraded
infrastructure convenience and safety
are their top priorities those old
bridges are not going to stand forever
that's the number one reason that we're
looking to implement this the second one
is the crash rates on the freeway we
want to build a freeway that is safer we
want to fix that ramp spacing which will
fix the congestion
in several miles in each direction and
dot has a couple of ideas to how they
want to rebuild things either by
replacing the bridges with a recessed
freeway or an elevated freeway on
embankment resident stephen franklin
says if an elevated freeway is added he
would like to see something substantial
created under it if they do an elevated
version that it ties that neighborhood
together and activates that land and
makes that an amenity for the
neighborhood rather than a dead zone i
feel
that a great option is to provide some
park space currently the downtown access
project is looking like an eight to nine
year process we're in the environmental
phase we will finish that phase by 20
middle of 2023
the environmental phase is the only
phase that is currently funded the next
phase is the final design
after the final design that is when
construction will begin slated for 2027
to 2028 ndot put together videos for
each of the different proposals on the
project we'll have all that information
up on our website you can just click on
the link on the story reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now